I you know it's been amazing to spend
some time with the students here at UCL
who have come together to organize
donations for people in Turkey who are
affected by this awful tragedy and I'm
sure this is being replicated across the
country it's really hard actually to
comprehend the scale of the tragedy that
has happened almost 20 000 people have
lost their lives I mean I as a dad
watching Parents try and find their
young children in the rubble is
heartbreaking and we will do everything
that we can to help turkey I already
said that to the president when I spoke
to him a couple of days ago and what the
government's also said is that we will
match all of the country's donations
pound for pound so if anyone can give to
the disasters emergency committee then
the government will match your donation
pound for pound and we can get that
extra help to Turk in Syria too you're
mentioning the um
yeah so I spoke to Turkish president a
couple of days ago told him we'll do
everything we can the most impressing
thing that he asked me for was search
and rescue teams which we sent earlier
this week 77 specialized search and
rescue teams who were on the ground
First Responders trying to help find
people who are trapped by the rubble
we're also sending thousands of pieces
of equipment for people to just be safe
in the short term so that's tense that's
blankets that's clothes it's sanitation
equipment and we're also providing extra
funding to the white helmets
organization in Syria who are providing
humanitarian assistance on the ground
but we will continue to do what is
required to provide support but it's
inspiring to be with groups like this
here at UCL amongst the students who are
organizing donations from communities
it's fantastic and that's why the
government's Keen to support as well